high-stakes Hollywood laborer showdown
could knock some of your favorite TV
shows off the air members of the Writers
Guild of America voted overwhelmingly
last night to authorize a strike for the
first time in ten years they have less
than a week to work out a new contract
with producers they avea al is at a
production sound stage in Los Angeles
with the potentially costly battle but I
good morning good morning shows like the
Roseanne Barr show The Mary Tyler Moore
Show and the Gilligan's Island show were
shot right here in this studio sound
stages like this have never been busier
four hundred and fifty five of them were
built just this season compared to
that's more than about six years ago
more than double then about six years
ago that is right now
writers are saying that we've seen more
content coming in from Amazon to Hulu
and Netflix and now they want their pay
to reflect Hollywood's new reality for
now it's all smiles on the late-night
talk shows doctor say if you've already
ingested piece of pieces of golf balls
the best thing to do is just let them
play through but all those jokes come
from Union writers who could soon be
putting their pens down and putting
those shows in jeopardy the Writers
Guild announced Monday that more than
6,300 of their members voted by a margin
of 96% to authorize a march on the
picket lines if a deal isn't reached
with the producers union before their
current contract expires on May 1st your
upcoming fall lineup favorites could
also take a hit sharing I skipped
kindergarten may have to fight back TV
writer and guild member Patti Carr has
worked on shows like rain and private
practice
she says changes in the TV landscape
have hurt the bottom line for writers
because they are paid per episode a
traditional broadcast series runs 22 to
24 episodes but now shows on cable or
basic streaming services run an average
of just 12 episodes
these shows are often shot to look more
like a movie taking longer in production
which keeps riders tied up for the same
amount of time while making less money
the average income for the four writers
has gone down 23% it's about not being
able to sustain yourself writers are
asking for higher script fees bigger
residuals from streaming media and
larger contributions to their health
plan when unionized writers went on
strike 10 years ago it lasted more than
three months halting production on
dozens of TV shows and films it also
cost the industry at least 2 billion
dollars in a statement released Monday
night the producers Alliance said they
remain committed to reaching a deal but
warned the 2007 writers strike hurt
everyone writers lost more than two
hundred and eighty seven million dollars
in compensation that was never recovered
hopefully it doesn't come to that
it'll be hard it'll be scary if that's
what we have to do producers say they
are also under pressure to keep costs
down with viewers changing their viewing
habits and also cutting the cable cord
both sides believe that this strike is
avoidable and talks will resume today in
Los Angeles Charlie all right thanks